[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela blando Daniela Buen día para
usted Hola Muy buenos días Ángela una
historia que parece demasiado familiar
otra aerolínea colombiana suspende las
operaciones claro entonces hace un mes
estábamos hablando y duramos muchos días
hablando de viva Air la aerolínea más
grande de bajo costo en Colombia ahora
vamos a hablar entonces de Ultra Pues
con menos de un año en el mercado esta
empresa colombiana de capital colombiano
puso fin a su operación de manera
repentina después de que sus accionistas
no aprobaran una nueva capitalización
también después de que días antes la
chilena Jet Smart se arrepintiera de
ejercer una opción de compra para salvar
a esta compañía entonces la compañía
dice que no tiene recursos para seguir
operando y entre otros factores Como por
ejemplo la devaluación del peso frente
al Dólar también el alza en el precio
del combustible debido por supuesto al
incremento en los del petróleo culpa
también de su situación a la quiebra de
viewer lo que dice exactamente Es que
puso en alerta esa quiebra a los
proveedores de la industria y a los
arrendadores de aeronaves quienes
empezaron a exigir y entre comillas
exigir pagos inmediatos e incluso
prepagos de los insumos y servicios algo
que es inusual en esta industria
aeronáutica Bueno aparte de estos temas
En qué se parece el caso al de Pues en
el caso de Ultra Air Aunque tiene
diferencia con viva Air trae a la
memoria lo ocurrido como decíamos hace
un mes que fue el cese de operaciones
sin previo aviso de viva Air que dejó a
muchos pasajeros con tiquetes comprados
tuvieron que ser reacomodados En otras
aerolíneas Aunque Esta vez tiene una
particularidad Ángela y es que se da
justo antes de la temporada alta de
Semana Santa cuando Los tiquetes son más
escasos y desde luego son más costosos
lo llamativo de este asunto es que
apenas horas antes de anunciar que
dejaba sus contados aviones en tierra
esa empresa ultraer seguía enviando
correos como este que vamos a ver a
continuación lo estamos viendo acá Este
fue un correo que personalmente me llegó
a mí y me ha venido llegando durante
toda la semana correos de esta aerolínea
promocionando tiquetes
hay que recordar que en el caso de las
autoridades investigaron prácticas como
esta porque van en detrimento de los
derechos de los usuarios Y es que están
ofreciendo mire compra el marzo 28 y
viaja de marzo 28 de 2023 a febrero 29
del 2024 apenas horas antes de decir no
vamos a operar más algo que también está
en la mira de las autoridades el
ministro de transporte aseguró que ya
pidió la lista de pasajeros con tiquetes
comprados para gestionar o bien la
devolución o la modificación de la
reserva también hay otros aerolíneas que
se ofrecieron a reacomodar pasajeros y a
brindar tarifas especiales pues en estos
días que son tan demandados No pues es
que Imagínese uno quedarse sin avión
faltando tres días para irse a sus
vacaciones de semana santa y además
mejor dicho si no vio noticias ayer pues
no se enteró y pudo caer en lo que sería
una trampa en lo que sería una trampa
porque ellos ya desde días antes sabían
que venían con una mala situación y lo
curioso de este asunto es que vuelve y
nos pasa lo mismo entonces
no hay que culpar desde luego a las
personas Pero esta aerolínea ya venía
con problemas así que pues es en este
momento no es recomendable comprar esa
clase de tiquetes precaución precaución
nos vamos a cambiar de tema de elon Muse
pide una pausa en el desarrollo del chat
chat gpt sí Ángela Es de Magnate dueño
de Twitter y de muchas otras compañías
es uno de los cofundadores del líder de
la industria Open que es desarrollado
como lo sabemos por Microsoft y también
su fabricante de automóviles tesla
utiliza Inteligencia artificial para su
sistema de piloto automático pues más de
mil personas incluidos él y también un
grupo de expertos en Inteligencia
artificial también ejecutivos de la
industria están pidiendo una pausa de
seis meses en el desarrollo de sistemas
más potentes que él recientemente
lanzado gpt de Open una carta abierta
que cita riesgos potenciales para la
sociedad con este tipo de tecnologías
que han cautivado a los usuarios al
involucrarlos en conversaciones
similares a las humanas componiendo
canciones o resumiendo documentos
extensos o declarándose a las personas
tiene un montón de herramientas lo que
no dice la carta es que el mes pasado
tesla tuvo que retirar más de 362 mil
vehículos en Estados Unidos eso para
actualizar el software después de que
los reguladores dijeran que este sistema
de asistencia al conductor generado con
Inteligencia artificial podría causar
accidentes cuando eso ocurrió el
multimillonario señaló la Inteligencia
artificial artificial me estresa pues
esto una experta consultada por France
24 sobre esta carta en esta carta dice
vamos a llegar a un punto en el que
probablemente necesitemos analizar Cuál
será el el momento en el que tengamos
que ponerle un límite al crecimiento de
estos modelos entonces en la carta que
firman elon musk Russell Steven están
diciendo ese punto es ahora y ya han
existido otros puntos en los que
anteriormente también se ha puesto un
freno a estos avances Pero esto es
principalmente porque están diciendo
Bueno estamos listos para que exista un
sistema que pueda ser eventualmente
más inteligente que el que los humanos
en el caso que se desarrollara un
sistema de Inteligencia artificial
general o que pudiera ponernos que
pudiera dejarnos obsoletos él se estresa
Imagínese los usuarios afectados Pues yo
yo no estaría tan estresada si fuera él
bueno en Alemania para cambiar de tema
Daniela no hubo acuerdo entre el
gobierno y los empleados públicos
cuéntenos Pues en recuerde usted Angela
que el lunes el transporte de la
economía más grande de Europa se vio
paralizado por una huelga de 24 horas
liderada por sindicatos del sector
público ellos piden aumentos salariales
para hacerle frente a la creciente
inflación tras días de negociaciones no
hubo acuerdo con el gobierno por lo que
ahora vendrá un intento de arbitraje
cuyo fracaso podría sí llevar a una
huelga indefinida este proceso garantiza
que no habrá paros al menos hasta el 13
de abril lo que les da un respiro
relativo a Los viajeros de la ajetreada
Semana Santa en este país el sindicato
verdi pide un aumento salarial del 10,5%
para 2,5 millones de trabajadores frente
a una inflación anual que se ubica en el
9,6% en todo caso las propuestas que les
han hecho por parte del ejecutivo pues
no los han convencido y en otros asuntos
también de Europa la Unión Europea
aprieta sus medidas de consumo de
energías limpias sube la apuesta sube la
apuesta porque mire se he visto que para
2030 el bloque comunitario lograra que
el 32% de total de su canasta energética
correspondiera a energías renovables hoy
en día ese esa proporción es del 22%.
ahora lo que hay es un nuevo objetivo
que este tipo de energía por ejemplo la
eólica o la solar representa el 42,5%
para ese entonces 2030 inclusive el 45%
en su meta más optimista Esta es un
acuerdo vinculante alcanzado por los
negociadores que de todas maneras pues
va a tener que ser confirmado por la
eurocámara también por el consejo de la
Unión Europea el objetivo final de todo
esto es acelerar la transición ecológica
para poder alcanzar la neutralidad
climática a mitad de siglo y el
principal obstáculo en las negociaciones
será que Francia y otra decena de países
defendían que el hidrógeno que se
obtiene de la energía nuclear Debería
ser considerado renovable pero otros
países como España y Alemania se oponían
decían de de todas maneras es una
energía que se está generando a partir
de una fuente no renovable bueno esto
sigue siendo muy polémico le voy a pedir
que cerremos con su cifra del día que
trae buenas noticias para algunos
Trabajadores al menos una buena noticia
el 12% que subirá el salario de más de
26.000 colaboradores de la empresa
minorista primark en Reino Unido a
partir del próximo primero de abril esto
según anunció la compañía y es que este
país tiene la más alta inflación entre
sus vecinos un 10,4% interanual en
febrero y ha sido epicentro de numerosas
huelgas por parte de los trabajadores
que precisamente están exigiendo más
ingresos para contrarrestar esta alza de
precioso Daniela Le agradezco nos vemos
más adelante para actualizar las
noticias económicas en una hora estoy
aquí puntualidad